[Musik]
mit lufthansa führt als auch russland
guten tag meine damen und herren ich
begrüße sie zur mittags aufgabe der
tagesschau hörte ich sie benennen jockey
das getraut sich immer mehr aber sie
schaffte macchiato café melange schnitt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der rassismus core networks und die
besorgte worte die sind zum größten teil
gar nix ch allerdings nicht die erste
schwarze news moderatorin des schweizer
fernsehens ihre hautfarbe wollte sie nie
zum thema machen
doch dieser sommer hat ihr leben
verändert
[Musik]
sechster juni 2020 tausende von menschen
gehen in der schweiz auf die straße und
protestieren gegen rassismus im eigenen
land celik welt kommt in ein dilemma
diese strategie hat sich bleibt
womöglich mit weh tut und es zeigt sich
die tante separatismus
praktisch mir get all your retten
es zeigt sich hatten sie das muss
entschuldigen wie zum beispiel das ist
es nicht was gemeint
bislang fiel sexy und das ist bitter
sagt der solidarität die sie fingen dass
man sie zu fördern
es ist mitte august fällig peltner ist
auf dem weg ins berner oberland
[Musik]
in frutigen hat sie die ersten jahre
ihrer kindheit verbracht die mutter war
zu der zeit leere denn im dorf sie
unterstützt außerdem bendtner bei der
aufarbeitung ihrer geschichte aber nicht
vor der kamera
jetzt geht sie zur großtante bei der sie
damals zusammen mit ihrer mutter gewohnt
hat
[Musik]
großtante leadership und deren tochter
beatrice gehörten zu den engsten
bezugspersonen in angelique bildnis
kindheit über rassismus oder ihre
hautfarbe hat sie mit ihnen noch nie
gesprochen
genau studiert doch heute chefin des
projektes netter heide verfangen habe
staunte gilt familie und wir das auch
verständlich gemacht
das macht halt sehr friedlich sie ins
kiesbett und beschnitten als ob sie
sagen jetzt plötzlich richtig und dunkel
wurde
wohlbehütet sei sie aufgewachsen sagt
angelique beltzner zu allein erziehenden
mutter mit dem schwarzen unehelichen
kind habe kaum jemand fragen gestellt
[Musik]
die familie wird angesehen im dorf
außer league geltendes vater war weit
weg der informatiker aus paris und ihre
mutter waren drei jahre ein paar
vor der geburt der gemeinsamen tochter
trennte sich die mutter von ihm oder was
hat mein arbeitsweg sie wirklich dass
auch reale situation umgesetzt
das ist natürlich sehr wichtig ist gut
im wechsel war umgekehrt sie tätigen
geschafft vielleicht also ich denke ich
hätte meine ganze familie luft
inmitten einer weißen umgebung wuchs
angelique petzner auf seit ihrer
kindheit stecke dieses gefühl vom sich
anpassen wollen tief innen drin
dazu gehören zu einer weißen mehrheit
behält ist es somit begriff zum beispiel
die ganze moore hoff depeschen fort
das hänge noch geprüft und das sehen
viele empfindlich reagiere wenn er sie
hat einen schock sagte der musiker hinzu
kommt das verstauen oder sticks ich
dabei geblieben wenig das wäre natürlich
die auf passivhaus österreich fragte ich
finde das absolut
das muss man nicht extra sprach ich bin
nicht da sein muss erzählt schon mal
begegnet
verteidiger soll unterstütze ich nicht
so wichtig und gibt mit einem gewicht ab
- erst als rené lohs stück vorne und
zwar ganz und gar nicht schwarz maus
spiel ist man ja nicht lustig vorne
ja das kann ich ja gleich es ist es
spiele mit das wort auf sehe ich beziehe
gegen aus darauf passt aber sehr gut
zudem dass es langsam besser gefahren
bgh sprecher
was für mehrfache ist humor hawks
akzeptierte und jetzt akzeptieren wie du
bist du deine hobbys und mit minute aus
als diskussion und nicht am start ua
standpunkt unterblieb schon oft haben
ist natürlich für mich es ist schwierig
gewesen ich denke wir sehen uns eher
minimal die große sorge sei dank
und ist es heute noch okay mohrenkopf zu
sagen oder gehört der begriff dorthin
woher kam nämlich ins neunzehnte
jahrhundert eine tradition verletzt und
würdigt das erstmals zu benennen sei
nicht einfach sagt celik welt nicht
das problem ist natürlich das signal
also bisher gestellt werden
es ist nicht zum beispiel empfindlich
[Musik]
und hofläden der schwede kompliziert die
sie ausgeschafft an boni aus negative
eigenschaften enrique boni mit wenig für
das team ico nicht wenn ihr jetzt raus
also dass du das wort signum der musik
hofnarr dass man mir die sachen in ihrem
leben nahm sie bisher denn für sie
einfach einen blick schweigen dass man
im vergleich zu hintergehen hatten sie
neben erkennen er hat für kaffee was
machen sie jetzt mit täglich begonnen
das virus lebt
wer so hinter die geschichte es ist
schon so dass stephanie zumindest so
genau was möglich ist
es ist nicht möglich mit dem licht oder
was immer der glaube ich möglichst
aber ich bin ja nicht aus zucker wollte
genau so genau wusste was los alamos
motto steht
[Musik]
das ist die erste tagesschau an diesem
heißen mittwoch ich begrüße sie zur
sendung mit diesen themen slf chef
stylistin tatjana kotowa ordnet den
auftritt ein debian sf moderatorin
moderator in hammerau für angelique bei
der moderation stadt im 2015 skylink
weil das im youz passt also elegant und
ausdrucksstark und styling richtlinien
2015 zurück sie das denn kleider wertet
elegant wirkt aber nicht durch volumen
oder dominanz zu sehr vom inhalt
ablenken und das ist es wichtig sie bei
allen moderatoren nachts eine kita haben
wir immer beurteilt inzwischen des
business mode viel lockerer wurde
freibeträge vielmehr sie die bluse mit
chip oder kleider und der lockere 3 25
jahre ist es her
heute trägt ihr haar am bildschirm auch
offen haar und hautfarbe sind die
offensichtlichen merkmale die darauf
schließen lassen dass sie einen anderen
kulturellen hintergrund hat doch damit
liegt man bei ihr grundfalsch
das hans rink machte hat die frage kann
aus stahl um die haben mich gefragt habe
wichtig und richtig homo richtiges
bleiben obwohl sie die wurzel kann ich
sehe kein normaler sich die sitzreihen
das war typisch dass wenn man sie fragen
immer und immer wieder
zwar sehr frühe im gespräch empfinde das
so soll man mir sagen du bist nicht
verdammen
mit sf chefredaktor tristan brenn will
sie erstmals über eine erfahrung im
fernsehen rieten die mit ihrer hautfarbe
zu tun hat das erste mal beworben ich
vor 15 jahren tagesschau und den hat man
mir gesagt schweiz ich noch nicht so wie
sie parat hat und gute moderatorin
mit hans-ulrich seidt fast nicht glaube
meine meriten damit vor dem weiß nicht
was ich vor 15 jahren hast du gesagt
und selbst wer dauernd ein gefühl
klarheit das könnten kritiker stoßen
anderer moderatorin war ein anderer
hautfarbe glaubte muss erst recht machen
und der schritt machen und diese
darstellen das hat mit ihr denn so zeit
als begründung oder wissen dass diese
technik ganz direkt direkt mit es gab
halt noch andere gründe dass irgendwo
was andere gewöhnt und dann
herausgestellt dass es ja bin sehr
überrascht über so eine lose sohn albert
ii
und ich sage mal so schlimm kommt
sowieso so dass sache indem ist krank
sie und er haut dankt verstoß ist stolz
wenn wir doch nicht weiß wie das land da
ist es vielleicht zu lassen aber das ist
ja der hersteller denkt ja fernseh
zuschauer und zuschauerinnen die sie als
mensch abwerten weil sie eine andere
hautfarbe hat die gibt es zum beispiel
mit dem e-tron und daggy wo negativ sehe
aber noch nicht ganz rund wird der
antike sagen ob das mit rassismus hat
und das werde zum beispiel
die frau beschrieb die angebote für das
geknutsche gar nicht die kultur der
schweiz sei bedroht wenn er schwarze
menschen das öffentliche bild prägen so
eine umfrage des bundesamtes für
statistik aus dem jahr 2017
wir sind zurück in frutigen am
stammtisch des restaurants im plus
celik beltzner stellt sich der rassismus
diskussion warum zb streams
wir sagen ja
[Musik]
das ist schwarz
sie ist das was sie sagen
[Musik]
da brauchst du eine definition von
rassismus ist menschen auf jeder
herkunft reduzieren ihnen kollektive
merkmale zu schreiben und sie deswegen
herabsetzen
in europa kann ich ja unser beruf
berichten wenn der schritt sei der
schwarze schön dass sie die anderen
parteien gebräunt ja mit kommen dass mit
ihnen raus
das glaube ich nicht aus ihren fragen
woher das war ja zum beispiel kommen
dass brasilien
man kriegt ja mit der gerne singt
[Musik]
damit er das auch das regenchaos jetzt
wirklich stolz nichts verspürt die
straßen es sieht nicht nur die frage was
sie interessantes argument
[Musik]
wie können wir als gesellschaft mit
rassismus und vertritt gedanken 40
people kolat hat auch für einige
verbraucher denkt ganz bestimmt nicht
ich bin ich und mir 2
und das wäre schön sie und wenn man denn
tun hat jetzt sprechen die schwarzen den
serbischen übrigen es ist 50 50
diese sendung wurde heftig kritisiert
von debakel und fiasko war die räte weit
weg von einer konstruktiven rassismus
diskussion der auftritt von angelo auto
war für angelique welt hat wegweisend
und mit anderen egal
und die hat nicht gewusst was sie hatte
angst machen damit auch und und er denkt
genau so oft es geht um
es geht ums schwarze und ich höre da die
zwischen wort
angelique beltzner trifft die black lips
matte aktivistin angelo amato bei einem
konzert in zürich
[Musik]
sie will mit angelo auto über die
sendung sprechen und welche folgen diese
für sie hatte ich hatte am anfang die
erste frage wo zum hervor
ich trage sie geht es das was jetzt
passiert es schwierig und es ist mir nie
wirklich dank der schweiß und wenn ich
mir die hand ganz recht sein und das
sanierte straße hast du dir selbst und
ganz ehrlich strohmann ist oder zucker
wieder 600 euro liegt und ich gar nicht
wohin mit mir nachher hinter mir
gestanden sind
ich meine kommen vier aus nachrichten
über das bestätigt genau ist das wenn
ich mache aber wichtig ist und die erste
die notwendig
das wirklich wo er ist im alltag aus
schwarzer menschen wieder fort meinte
zimmer für lügner vertuschen
das wort casting ist soll es wichtig
sword wird es ist das was man im alltag
immer wieder erlebt dass die schüler
dort nicht erwartet dass das geht es
nicht
rassismus erfahrungen absprechen
die beiden frauen haben es zur genüge
erlebt
maria jung unsere ziel es ist september
außer liegt belz mit auf dem weg zu
ihrem vater
[Musik]
mit 20 jahren hat sie ihren leiblichen
vater zum ersten mal gesehen
man hat mir gesagt dass ich die fehler
man hat zwar gesagt wo hat es um ein
paar wenige sachen wenn ein geschenk das
ich war eben nur hacker aber schon vater
und die geschichte mit ihrer herkunft
verbunden ist vor der mallinie bis meter
geholt
in paris hat sie drei geschwister ihr
vater kommt ursprünglich aus der
ehemaligen französischen kolonie benin
der kontakt ist lohse sie habe die
schwarze familie auf distanz gehalten
sagt sie seien willkommen bei dir zu
hause geht es gut und den kindern sehr
gut
ich freue mich dich zu sehen ja ich mich
auch es ist lange lange her vor 24
jahren haben die jungs zum ersten mal
gesehen
ich war damals 20
du warst 20 damals angaben wie war das
für dich damals also ich sah war ich
glück überglücklich es war ein wunder
du bist meine tochter meine erste
tochter
ich habe diesen sommer gemerkt dass ich
endlich auch meine andere seite meine
schwarze seite annehmen muss und darüber
sprechen kannst du das verstehen
ja ich verstehe dass du geboren wurdest
war ich nicht an seiner seite
ich weiß du hast darunter gelitten ich
dafür meine anwesenheit hier gefehlt
über rassismus villa seines vater an
diesem tag nicht sprechen
für dinge die ihn belasten gehe in die
kirche
[Musik]
ja
am nächsten tag ist die schwester zu
hause mit ihr spricht das lichtbild nur
das thema rassismus an dir was du
rassismus erlebt natürlich und du hast
ihn durch mich erlebt damals in der
sekundarschule in der sekundarschule ja
da hast du gelitten
ich kann mich nicht mehr an genaue worte
erinnern
aber es war die schwarzen jetzt hast du
gedacht wie war das für dich
es war hart man fühlt sich allein und
findet keine worte um sich zu
verteidigen
dieses thema anzusprechen
er geht
wir werden ihn fragen warum er
ausgerechnet jetzt geht das du mit ihm
darüber gesprochen
nein wir haben noch nie darüber
gesprochen hatte angst oder wäre es
nicht glauben
auch er glaubt es
er hat ja damals in der schule
interveniert und ich sind aber ich
glaube es ist auch für ihn schwierig es
ist einfacher alles zur seite zu
schieben und so zu tun als ginge alles
gut würde rassismus nicht existieren so
wirkt wenn man nicht darüber spricht ist
es als wäre es nicht passiert
aber warum hast du nicht darüber
gesprochen
einmal habe ich es erzählt und dann ich
weiß nicht hat man mir die möglichkeit
gegeben wirklich darüber zu reden
es war vielleicht auch der wunsch mich
integrieren zu wollen und diesen
gefühlen gar kein gewicht zu geben dann
geht es vorbei warum bist du raus
gegangen halte ich muss etwas holen
gehen damit dies nicht vergesse für
seine heimreise mit dem rassismus ist es
besser oder
es ist immer noch da oder weniger auch
mehr oder weniger es ist darüber
ich war zum beispiel kürzlich mit einer
reinigungskraft auf der pflegestation
ich bin schwarz sie ist weil die
angehörigen die sich informieren wollten
und haben sich aber nicht an mich
sondern an die weiße frau gefahr nicht
verstehe
im kopf der menschen sitzt diese
hierarchie einfach fest der schwarze
mensch bleibt minderwertig damals als
ich mit seiner mutter zusammen war
da gab es nicht viele weiße die mit
einem schwarzen ausgegangen werden deine
mutter hat es gemacht die tatsache dass
sie das gemacht hat macht es sich zu
einer kämpferin gegen den rassismus die
trennung von schwarzen und weißen das
wollte sie nicht
das ist gut das ist
das ist gut aber man muss auch den
rassismus sprechen
du sprichst aber nur über die positiven
sachen aber es gibt auch die negativen
sachen ja die gibt es immer wir müssen
gar nicht versprechen
ja wir müssen darüber reden damit das
aufhört
das ist weniger wird ja da bin ich voll
und ganz mit ihr einverstanden oder
prozent einverstanden
[Musik]
die maus hat dank dass der hsv so
intensiv wird
[Musik]
für mich ist erschreckend jedes jahr -
schwarze familie die gleiche strategie
weiterhin
[Musik]
so wie eigentlich auch mini wie sie
familie der st
über rassismus zweites schwierig
ob es spiegel
ist für mich definitiv keine option mehr
[Musik]
er hat da schlägt das immer mit der
kamera begleitet muss sich extrem viel
über versteckten rassismus klebt und
frank lädt das mitwisser unmögliche
beurteilen
bis aus rassistisch empfunden
wahrscheinlichkeit mir viele fragen
beantwortet werden fragen der stelle es
im kommentar zum thema diese ganzen
beantworten
und überhaupt wer durch umlaufende
bliebe das bedeutende potter läuft die
abonnieren diesen kanal